Well, the fans are filing in here at Smartless Arena, and we're ready for a great game. I think that all the teams today are ready to go, and there's a lot on the line here, so let's see how they do over here on an all-new Smartless. Listen, I just want to say this, Jay, because I haven't, until now, I think it's so brave for you with your eyewear to go Sally, Jesse, Raphael, because I love the look. For me, I love it. Sally, Jesse would be a red, yeah, this is a black. But those do look like the same shape.
They're the same shape, yeah, they are the same shape. Wait, am I usually wearing a different pair of glasses? I don't know, but for some reason today, they're casting you in a different light. They're casting you in a different role. Well, maybe it's because I'm suffering deeply from COVID. No. Maybe that's what you're seeing, Will. You don't have it.
Why don't you have a little bit more sympathy for me, because I'm lousy with COVID? You really haven't. Yeah, but I didn't cancel today. I'm going to fight through, and I'm going to do a great session. Wait, do you feel like shit? No, I'm on day six, so I'm still testing positive, but the symptoms are all but gone. I don't know if you can, I still sound a little kind of 1993 Sunday morning, you know, a little backed up, a little schnitzy.
Oh no. Yeah. So, you've had to tough it out there at your house. It's not that tough. I've been there. It's the old goose shack. I'm feeling goose shack, the goose, remember he was a chronic master-bater, apparently. Okay, can I tell you, you want to hear a funny story about it, though?
Sorry, let me just close the COVID loop for once, and let me say thank you to all the geniuses that developed this vaccine, because I could tell that this is, I've had a pretty minor thing, you know, but were it not for the vaccine, I could tell this would not just be a cold. Yeah. This would be, there's a little engine in this thing, that the vaccine neutralizes pretty well, so thank you to the smart folks in the world, the scientists and whatnot. So you're welcome.
Well, yeah, from Sean and I, from the bottom of both of our hearts, you're welcome. And dark, cold hearts. What are you going to say, Will? So there's a, in this, where I'm, where I currently am, and I'm going to, let's just keep it anonymous, because I don't want to, but there's a, there's a certain chain department store nearby here. One of the people on our crew, he tells me that there is a, on a certain app on his phone, it's used for male hookups, that the, that the bathroom and changing room at this place
has glory holes. What's the address? What's the address? Hold on. Wait. Did you, was there an ass on the end of hole? Holes. So.
I want to, can we double back to the multiple holes, because I got questions, but go ahead. For sure. And so as we're working on the show, I have worked it into virtually every aspect of hosting this thing, people talking about their Lego and their build, and this thing has a hole on it, and I go, somebody did a cruise ship, I said, you know, the only cruising I do is in the men's department over at blah, blah, blah, and the contestants have no idea what I'm talking about. And all the crew are dying because everybody now knows about this.
Wait, who told you this? A guy on our, a guy that I work with, who's on one of these apps that's for, for hooking up with other dudes, and goes, guess what, you'll never believe, like less than a mile from here is a full hookup thing, glory, plural, holes at this place. And I said, why wouldn't it just be hookups? Why is it glory holes? Like, is that a real thing? And he said, yes.
That's like leftover from the 80s. I didn't know that existed anymore. So first of all, the general concept of the glory hole is you can go ahead and you can put yourself in there and see what you get kind of thing. Or is it, is it first of all, it depends on what side of it you're on. That's right. Well, I love that you guys are, you can ask me. Well, Sean, have you ever been to a glory hole?
No. Uh-uh. But, but is the concept that you're too ashamed to have a face to face hookup and that you just want to put it in the mystery box? To be honest, I don't understand because the mystery box, you don't know what's on the other side. You don't know the age, the STD level of that person. Then that was my next question.
If you have multiple holes, and so I'm imagining that they vary in girth. And so will that then tell you a, where you sit in the, in the whole scale of things, but also what, what, what you're, what you're hoping is on the other side. I don't, but see, I don't know if it's ever, ever revealed. I don't think it's ever revealed. You never get revealed. I think we're, are we, are we crafting a new reality show that like there's a reveal on the other side of somebody?
Well, aren't you just kind of, were you, can, why, why don't you, Oh, I want to go over there so bad. Yeah. Go over there with your iPhone and just photograph what these holes look like. And maybe what sort of, what sort of language there is that we're going to be like, we haven't heard from Will in two hours. And the other thing is that we drive by every morning, it's like seven a.m. we drive every day and just there's like a line and it's like the
mayor, the local pastor, like all these, they're all coming out of the shop, right? And they're all in there. And then the manager of the place is like, man, I mean, we got a line backed up here every day, but we do not move a lot of product. But everybody, it just seems to everybody's all filled up before they come in here. They empty and they leave their empty or they go, they go in the dressing room and I guess nothing fits. We got the wrong product.
None of our product is fit in anybody. That is there. Can you imagine my delight when he told me this? Yes. When he told me that this was going on, I was he, by the way, does he frequent this place? No, he hasn't gone. He hasn't gone.
But he sure that's what he says. That's what he said. Yeah. All right. Well, you go, you bring us back a video, would you? I'll keep you guys posted. Sorry, anyway. And then send it to me as well.
All right. So this is a perfect segue. Okay. And to our guest. Okay. Wow. I can best describe our guest today as that guy from that thing. But truly he's in everything.
You may know him from SNL, which doesn't narrow it down much, although he's credited for co-creating Bill Hader's iconic character of Stefan. He's got not one, but three Netflix comedy specials. He stars as a chipmunk and Chip and Dale rescue rangers on Disney plus. Boy, does he make me laugh. Yes. Mr. John Mulaney. John Mulaney.
John Mulaney has. Look at him. Hey. John, what do you have to say about the whole glory whole thing before we wrap that up? Is it drywall? Good question. Because I always thought it was the wall of a bathroom stall, which would be metal. Metal.
Right. Yeah. No, that's a separator. Right. That's for wide stance folks. It would have to be drywall. Yeah. Or plywood.
Yeah. That's scarier. Yeah. I've got to go check it out. I mean, obviously, I'm just obsessed with knowing the answer to all of this. Sure. I just want to know what's written around it, you know, like usually somebody's really kind of really running their mouth there when they write shit on a separator, right, between
a stall. On a separator, but you think maybe there'd be more grace and dignity to the glory hole, where it's like there's no need to write crude things. Some sort of encouraging line, you know. The act itself. Because it's about love. Yeah. And this is, it's all love.
And we're going to move through it with love. Maybe it's a Washington Post thing, you know, your truth dies in the darkness. Go ahead and enter. Something like that. Yeah. You don't need all the arrows in the innuendo and the little limericks, which are in poor taste. Yeah.
Let's not be childish. We all know why we're here. It's a helmet on a helmet. Do you think that there's like some ink, ink hair, you know, like some drawing of some hair and stuff like that? Or is it just like a big smiley face? I'm sorry, what? Okay.
You can see if they have those screens you sometimes see in elevators that give you like the news, you know, they give you like limited financial and entertainment news in case you've got stamina. Yeah. If you're standing there for a while, you want to know. What if it says something like something inspiring, like, you know, when the football players run through it, like Notre Dame and there's something over the door, if there's just something real inspiring over it.
What would get you charged up, Will? What would you want to slap? Like go, go, go. You know, I don't know, like, you know, go forth. Go get them. Go get them. Go get them. You know, go bravely into the void or something.
You know what I mean? Let me tell you something. This is not the way we started our session with David Rebnick. Okay. I can assure you that. I know. I know. Mr. Milaney.
It is how you started with Vivek Murthy. I think you believe it. He will. He's almost the exact same banter. Which is very similar. It's a major left. But that was more about the dangers of a glory hole. I know.
Yes. Because he's got to be that guy. He has to. John Milaney. Thank you for being here today. John Milaney. I'm very, very flattered to be here. I've listened to, I think, almost every episode of this show.
No. We have. Well, will you listen to your own? Absolutely. Yeah. All right. Good. John Milaney.
I'm such a, and I think we all are such big fans. Your last Saturday Night Live was so, they all, they're all great. But that last one was so fucking funny. Your monologue was genius. I was like, it was so funny. How do you find such comfort? Where's comfort in such ease? Is it because you've been there so long?
I think it is like home, right? It is a little bit like, yeah, it's like going back to school in a way because you fall right back into the same, like fall back into the same insecurities and securities. And in terms of doing the monologue, it's so scary. And it's so many people that it's laughable. I think I get relaxed because if something went wrong, it would go so wrong. Right. And there'd be no way around.
No one could talk me down and go, it's okay that you accidentally. And you can't blame anyone else because you're writing your own monologue, right? Yes. And it's you right into the, not right into the lens, but basically. Basically into the lens. Milaney, the first, so you first got hired at SNL as a writer, correct? Yes. But then you performed.
Yeah, just interrupt, John. Go ahead and just, yeah. So then. No, no. Let me say something. Let me say something. Good. You're right.
I was hired as a writer. Okay. Fucking. God, Sean. And then you. So wait, listen, John. Wait, Sean, we haven't moved on yet. When I wanted to interrupt.
Wait, this has got to be a great question. Hold on, everybody. Get it, Sean. No, I was going to say, you were, before SNL, you were discovered from the Conan, from late night with Conan. Is that true? And how did that go down? Like somebody, who saw you on that and what was that like?
The talent department at SNL saw me on Conan. Hang on, what's a talent department at SNL? What does that mean? It's the most, it's just the room of the most talented people in the world. Got it. We call them the talent. Got it. Let me see.
But you know, also, they saw me on Conan O'Brien, but I was doing ASCAT monologues that same summer. And I, with, when Amy and Seth were doing ASCAT a lot. So Amy Poehler, Seth Meyers were doing ASCAT, which is an improv thing at Upright Citizens Brigade. So. Which is at 20, which at that time was at 26th and 8th under Christieities. Yeah.
And they might have, you know, I haven't, I think they kind of floated my name there as well. That seems familiar. Yeah. Because I knew some folks that were working there. And the desire was to be a writer or performer or both? No, I auditioned as a performer, but it's so, I don't know, there's so much, it's so fluid between the two.
So you're doing, so you're doing monologues at ASCAT. How did you know Amy and Seth to do that? Like, did you learn on a improv team at UCB or anything? No, I was in it. I'd been an intern at UCB and I was taking classes there. When I first moved to New York in 2004, I was taking classes there and I was an intern there, which meant I was taping garbage bags to the ceiling so that McDonald's water could leak down into the theater without splashing on the good folks.
Did you start at 26th and 8th at that time? Yeah, I started at 26th and 8th. I'd been to the old, the first theater a couple times in college. And this was the second less fire hazard of the theaters. And I, yeah. So I was an intern, I was a janitor there on Saturday nights for, let's see, Respecto. Were they that night? Respecto Montalban.
Respecto Montalban. Classes that. For a while, the NYU Hammer Cats had a slot there. These are all improv teams. And I would watch them as I taped the garbage bags to the ceiling because water was actively leaked. Wait, Malanie, remind our audience who is in Respecto over the years. Let's see.
Oh, he's great. Owen Burke and the rest and all of them were in it. Well, Willie, didn't you, well, I did a monologue, didn't I, at Ascat? You sure did a couple of times. Remind me how that, I just remember that. You had the sniffles that night, I remember. Did I really? You had the Saturday night sniffles, I think.
Yeah, it was Sunday. Oh. Was I still enjoying? I don't know. But I remember it being very nerve wracking. Yeah, you did it a couple of times at 26 and eight. How did that go? Remind me.
I guess I was in a blackout or other things. It's a herald. Well, have Malanie remind you how it goes. John. Yeah. So you stand there and then you, do you get, don't you get sent like one word from the audience and then you got to do a whole, literally a, just do a, improvise a whole monologue about that one word, licorice.
You're scented in that they say it. You ask, yes, but you get, people yell out multiple words and I would say you pick the one closest to something you might have anything to say about. And then you just freestyle a story, but it has to last like five or 10 minutes, right? I think it's five minutes and it's supposed to be true. Yes. Oh, really? It's supposed to be a true story.
Yeah. Why do you make your shit up? I don't, I don't remember. I honestly don't, how long ago was that? Wasn't it like 20 years ago? That was like, that was like 2003. I mean, would it be fair to say, Will, that like it could be a full story with an arc, but almost, if you just gave details of anything, even if, even if you just, why would you just
walk us through a procedure? Yeah. Yeah. I would never, you, what, once you do it more and more, because really what you're there to do is you're in service of the improvisers who are standing on the stage behind you and you're trying to give them as many ideas to inspire them to create sketches, improvise sketches based on that. So, so, so, so, so what is with you today?
Fucking, I know you're the star of Good Night Oscar, but here there are other people. Okay. If you're in Chicago with your armed, with your fucking stellar reviews, you can just boss your way through shit, but here there are other people anyway, John, so sorry. But that was the thing, right, John? You're just trying to give them ideas. Yeah. You're just trying to give like texture and details.
I mean, they're not going to, they're not going to perform your story front to back. Right. And your story doesn't, what's, it's a front to back. That is the way to do it. Right? Sean, do you have something you want to show me? No, it's pretty good for my ass cat. Here we go.
It's really short. So, so Armani, the Armani, Giorgio Armani invited me. This is so long ago. We don't need the Armani, okay? Yeah. The Armani. And Armani. Yeah.
Somebody in the extended family. Like the puppy. Do you see how funny this is? Okay. Here we go. So we go to, he invited me to go to some fashion show in Milan. So I go there. Who?
Giorgio Armani. At the real Giorgio Armani. At the original. At the original. That's to be confused with Giorgio Armani, who lives in the North Valley here. Go ahead. So I go there, I go there, I watch the thing, and then he invites, there's this party at his house afterward.
And so I get one of the guys that works there. Wait, how is this related to Ascat? This is the, this is the story I told for Ascat. No, it was a gathering. Ascat's a gathering of people and it sounds like this is too. Yeah, sure. Wait, so you told the story of going to Armani's house? Yes.
And then I went to the house and I grabbed the guy who worked at the party and I said, I want to see the rest of his house. He's like, he really doesn't allow that. I'm like, please, please, please. So I go up to his, he gets in this elevator, I go up to his, the bedroom floor, right? And I go into his closet because I wanted to see what clothes he wore. And in his closet is all in a line, like 50 navy shirts and 50 pairs of jeans below it. All the exact same lined up.
The exact same, and it's all Tommy Hilfiger. And it's all Tommy Hilfiger. Were you, were you caught? It's all from the gap. I wasn't. I got, I high-tailed out there because I thought I was going to get shot or something. Did you take, did you steal anything? It'd be real.
No, no, no, I didn't steal anything. Great story. And now a word from our sponsor. All right. Back to the show. Anyway, listen, John, so you're from Chicago. I didn't know you're from Chicago. And you went, how long did you live here?
And you grew up here? Zero to 18. Yeah. I grew up in Lincoln Park. Wow. I didn't know that. Yeah. You're from Chicago.
You're from the Burbs. Yeah. Sean's in Chicago right now. I know. I can tell from his hat and the view and the fact that I know he's there. So I've always wondered what that, so listener, Sean has on a hat with the four stars and the blue stripe across the top and a blue stripe across the bottom. Is this a Chicago flag or an Illinois flag?
Chicago. So the city of Chicago has its own flag. Is that the city? Most cities do. LA doesn't have a city flag, does it? I'm sure it does. I'm sure it does. Yeah.
I'm sure it does. I'm doing a Google search right now. New York City does. Wait, wait, wait, Melinda, you'll be happy to know that when we were in Chicago doing our shows live that Sean's generous friend came by and brought us Chicago hats, 20 different Chicago hats, Chicago, like literally 20. Steve Orvath. Yeah.
Steve Orvath. Very kind of him. Yeah, so sweet. But I was like, how would we need to know? It was very generous. It sounds like it was a lot. It was a lot. It sounds like it was too many hats.
Steve Orvath. Very kind of him. Yeah, so sweet. But I was like, how would we need to know? It was very generous. It sounds like it was a lot. It was a lot. Sounds like it was too many hats.
Well, no. The way you're describing it, it's not, I'm not getting just a generosity vibe. It's a lot of hats. Yeah. The amount was surprising. Loved it. I will say this. Right.
You had to carry 20 hats for the tour, and you didn't want, you had to carry 20 hats in a laundry bag from the four seasons or something. Do you have merch at your shows, John? Yes. Thank you for mentioning that. That's short for merchandise. Sorry, John. What is your merchandise, John?
Wow. I get to plug the merch. I have a t-shirt that says, I saw him just after he got out of rehab. That would be the best seller right now. No way. Yes. It says that and has the tour. So John, so Melinda, you grew up in Chicago.
When did you start, did you start doing stand-up or did you start doing sketch? What was your trajectory? Outside of a high school environment, I started doing, I did stand-up at a couple, not even open mics, just like weird variety nights at places, like the note in your wicker park. But that's ballsy though, to just start to do stand-up, were you scared? I had weirdly high self-esteem when it came to that. Not really about any other part of life, but I was like, yeah, no, I'm a headliner. I guess I'm going to do this is going to be great.
People are going to be talking about this. And then I did improv in college. I auditioned for the improv group my fourth day of college and the director was a young man named Nick Kroll. Sure. Sure. He cast me. Yeah, he was a senior.
I was a freshman and he cast me in the improv group. Very much changed my life. That's amazing. Wait, where was this? What college was this? This was Georgetown University in Washington, D.C. Right. Were you studied theology as well?
Yeah. English and theology. Why? Oh, I thought. Want to be a priest? No, I mainly studied Jewish theology. There were a couple of very good Jewish studies professors at Georgetown and I just found it much more interesting theology because it's a lot more like, what the hell do we know?
Yeah. What do we know from anything? Yeah, Catholic was a lot more like, this is the, do this and you'll spend this many days in fire, but then you can get out if someone prays for you. There were too many rules, too much structure. Right. Judaism was a lot of like, who the hell are you to ask, you know, like, is there a God? Like, who the hell are you?
Sounds like shorter chapters, which is probably smart. Yeah. Excuse me? Who the hell are you to ask that? Why is there water? Get out of here. Get out of here. Mind you.
Now, were you a Weisenheimer in school when you were a little kid and that's where you thought maybe there might be a way to make a living here? I remember in third grade, a teacher gave me an article like Xerox from Esquire. Like it wasn't for kids. It was a, it was like an, it was an article and it was, it was about this guy, Henry Beard who wrote for the Harvard lampoon and the national lampoon and the name of the article was the original smart ass white guy and she slipped it to me, Miss Koal. And she said, you'd be into this guy and this type of thing.
That's cool. And yeah, it was cool. But I don't recall being like a troublemaker, but you knew that you had skills. You were making kids laugh. That felt good. Yeah. And you wanted more. And I was kind of a writer performer in that I would tell more poorly behaved children
what might be a funny thing to do. What if someone threw that out the window right now and they would take the bait and you would watch. Yeah. That'd be pretty, pretty crazy if someone just threw their potato battery out the window right now. Right. Can you imagine how that'd be crazy?
I know you're pretty unstable. God, you would have been. You've got a lot going on at home. Maybe you'd be like a king for a day if you did that. You know, I really was great. You'd be great in a cult. Do you know that? You'd be great if you worked in a cult.
I think I'd be pretty susceptible. I don't have a lot of cult confidence. I don't know how. I don't know if I'd be the leader. I think I'd be a member. And it'd take me a while to see the light. Are you saying there wasn't a lot of bad behavior when you were a little kid? Like because I'm just going through, as soon as you said battery, I had a horrible memory
of me and my friends throwing batteries at stuff. And there's more detail to that. I remember we got caught tagging up a garage. Yeah. We were always... You were in a tag crew? Yeah. And my tag...
Was hat sideways? Tell me the hat was sideways. No. Just a little skew. We wrote, we are the fuckers. Sure. And did you spell fuckers all weird? No.
Like scary weird? FUK. To me, it was just the declaration. We are the fuckers. Of what? Of what? Of everything, man, of anything, especially a garage door. You guys were hardcore.
So you could have gotten trouble if you'd gotten caught. You could have gotten trouble for a few dozen things when you were a kid or not. Yeah. I didn't have a pyromania phase, but my good friend did. And I would supervise. I kind of supervised that a little. You weren't mean to cats or anything, were you? Not at all.
No. Not at all. It was allergic to cats. So we had kind of agree to disagree relationship cats and I, but... Would you put like food coloring in beverages and things like that, John? No, but we would do a lot of like, what could we put a bottle of rocket in? What do you think he was in? A church group?
A church study theology and be in a real hell cat. But you're like the foreman of trouble. Like you just got everybody else creating trouble for you. The George Foreman of trouble? Yeah, you're like the German Foreman's Grill of Trouble. Yeah, I was. I was healthy, lean. Wait, so, so, so, John, so you go to, you go to...
Georgetown. and you're the guy running the improv team group, whatever. Well, now hold on a second. I gotta stop you there. I see John's got a Zevia beverage in his hand. Now that is- What's that? It is a Stevia based soda. And I can safely recommend every single flavor.
Hang on, John. You're not getting any freebies out of this. You're a guest. I don't need freebies, my recurring Amazon orders. I have two recurring Amazon orders that I, one, I don't know how to cancel and one, I can't find it. See, that's why I've never signed up for the automatic.
What is the one you don't know how to cancel? It's so much cream soda, but I'm fine with it, but it's backing up. There's baby formula diapers and so much cream soda Zevia. And they're tall boys too, because I just- Oh, I do like that. The tall ones are nice. They can make tall ones, yeah.
Now does that, that gets us into, you seem like a guy who watches what they put in their body. We're gonna double back to Georgetown. Sorry, are we back to the glory holes? Oh no. No. Yeah. We went all the way back.
So there's, is there no sugar goes into that body, John? No, sugar goes into this body. Yeah. I am, I am recently sober. And so I'm allowing myself a lot of- Sugar. Sugar and indulgences. Yeah.
I'm trying to cut back, but I haven't yet. Right. And I won't today, and I won't tomorrow. Watch out for the man with no vices. Go ahead and keep one or two. Yeah, sugar's just fine, work. I quit smoking cigarettes in November too. Oh, but-
How's that showing off? Stop showing off. I went to a, I went to a hypnotist. Yeah. He was a UCLA paranormal professor, who now hypnotizes people in his garage in Santa Monica. Sounds safe. Do you see spaceships when he's done?
I mean, honestly, none of this seems problematic to me. Keep going. Remember how I said I'm susceptible to cults? Well, I go to this guy's garage. He hits the side- I spent eight hours in the garage. So you're telling me the guy with the crystal ball, he moved his operation into the garage
and now he's getting people off butts? Like- Well, if he's so fake, how come he has some headshots thanking him for his work? Some headshots. Yeah, some sun-faded headshots thanking him for getting them off cigarettes. Entertainers who I recognize vaguely.
Wait, so did it work? I mean, are you craving cigarettes? It actually did work. I mean, I smoked from 13, age 13 to 39 and stopped in November after the second- Cold turkey. No weaning whatsoever. First hypnotism session,
you get to keep smoking for that week, which is a big reason I did it, was that I love smoking. So second session, walked out, never had another. Third session, I actually don't remember. I really did go somewhere else. That's nice. That's great.
So John Mulaney, I wanna talk to you about, Marty Short is a good friend of mine, good friend of ours. The greatest. And I loved your sitcom called Mulaney with Marty. Thank you. I did, I loved it. I watched it.
Wow, thank you very much. I watched the, on the tap over at Radford Studios, I would see you guys rehearsing all the time. It was so fun, it was one of the most fun experiences making the show. He speaks so highly of you, just so you know. I love him very much. Yeah, it's mutual.
I wanna see that, damn it. I apologize. 2014, Fox, from August to November of 2014. So it was a tight 13? I think they did air all 13. Our final episode aired against the SNL 40th, which I was working on, and we ended up losing to that,
the ratings that night. That's like the, Will, didn't they air the very final episodes of rest development against the winter Olympics? Opening of the Olympics, opening or closing. They burned all four in a row. And they didn't tell you, they were like, get these off our face. Salt Lake City, was it?
那天晚上的收视率。这就好像是，威尔，他们播出的《发展受阻》大结局，不是正好撞上了冬奥会吗？奥运会开幕式，开幕式还是闭幕式。他们一口气把四集全播完了。而且他们都没跟你说，他们就好像是，赶紧把这玩意儿从我们眼前弄走。是盐湖城对吧？
But Sean, was that sitcom? Sorry, Sean. No, that's okay. Was that something you always wanted to do? Were you passionate about it? Or? I was, I was passionate about, I was and am passionate about Multicam.
但肖恩，那部情景喜剧？抱歉，肖恩。不，没关系。那是你一直想做的事吗？你对它充满热情吗？还是？我是，我对情景喜剧充满热情，我曾经是，现在也依然充满热情。
I really like. Still, you and me both. So do we. Yep, and I, I mean, I grew up on them, but also I just find it, and maybe it's also the Saturday Night Live in me, and the stand up in me. I just like three to four cameras,
我真的很喜欢。依然如此，你我都一样。我们也是。没错，而且我，我的意思是，我是看着它们长大的，但同时我也发现，可能这也包含了我身上的《周六夜现场》基因，还有我的脱口秀基因。我就是喜欢三到四台摄像机，
and yelling jokes to the back of the room. And an audience, a live audience. And a live audience, yeah. And the six hour day. Oh my God. I mean, as the EP and writer and everything, I didn't have that, but watching Elliot Gould and Marty Short and Nassim Pedrad leave at three,
然后在房间后面对着大家大喊笑话。还有观众，现场观众。还有现场观众，对。以及六小时的工作日。天哪。我的意思是，作为执行制片人、编剧以及各种角色，我当时没有那种待遇，但看着埃利奥特·古尔德、马蒂·肖特和纳西姆·佩德拉德在三点钟离开，
I just thought, ooh, that's the life of King. Would you do another one? I would, yeah. Yeah? You should. Yeah, you should. We need to crack that. I'm calling you after this session.
我当时就想，哦，这才是人过的日子。你还会再拍一部吗？我会的，对。是吗？你应该去。对，你真该拍。我们得想办法搞定这个。我下场后就给你打电话。
Who directed most of those episodes? Do you remember? I just, when they're good, they're so great. Andy Ackerman, one of them. Sure. Oh yes. Seinfeld, yeah. Yeah, of course.
大多数集数是谁导演的？你还记得吗？我只是觉得，当它们优秀的时候，真的是太棒了。安迪·阿克曼，其中一集。当然。哦，对。杰瑞·宋飞，对。对，当然。
Seinfeld, many other great things. And then let me ask you this, because I've always wanted to know, I've always wondered about like, A plus stand up like yourself, who do all these specials in your tour, and you're constantly writing. By the time we see your special on Netflix or wherever it is,
宋飞，还有许多其他伟大的作品。然后让我问你这个，因为我一直很想知道，我一直很好奇，像你这样的一流脱口秀演员，做过所有这些专场和巡演，而且你一直在写作。等我们在网飞或其他地方看到你的专场时，
how many times have you tried out the material, or how many rewrites do you go through before we see it? Or are we seeing stuff that you trusted or know will work from the moment you wrote it? Oh, those seem like two questions. Yeah, it's a problem with Sean. So, yeah. Okay, the first part is,
你已经把这些素材试演过多少次了，或者在你推出它之前，你经历过多少次重写？还是说，我们看到的都是你从写下来那一刻起就信任并知道它行之有效的东西？哦，听起来这是两个问题。对，这就是肖恩的问题。所以，好吧。好吧，第一部分是，
it depends on how much I toured before the special. Yeah. So, I did that sitcom. It was, production was shut down in October. I went on the road the next week, and then I taped a special that May called The Comeback Kid for Netflix. That was a pretty short tour.
这取决于在专场演出之前我巡演了多少场。对。所以，我拍了那部情景喜剧。十月份制作停工了。第二周我就上了路，然后在次年五月为网飞录制了一个名为《逆袭小子》的专场。那是一次相当短的巡演。
The last special I did, there was about a year of touring before it. This one will be like, this one will be close to a year, maybe over. I'm on the road steadily right now. How do you like that road stuff, that touring stuff, that staying in a hotel every night? I love it.
我做的上一个专场，在它之前大约有一年的巡演。这一个大概会是，这一个将接近一年，甚至可能超过。我目前正在路上进行稳定的巡演。你觉得那种在路上的生活、巡演的生活、每天晚上都住在酒店里怎么样？我喜欢。
I like hotel living. I really like tour bus living. If you take your own slippers with you when you go to all those hotels. I bring my own pillow, but I take their pillowcase. What does that mean? Jason doesn't like,
我喜欢酒店生活。我真的很喜欢巡演大巴生活。如果你去所有这些酒店时都带上你自己的拖鞋。我带自己的枕头，但我用他们的枕套。这是什么意思？杰森不喜欢，
doesn't Jason won't walk on the floors of a hotel? He will not walk on the floors of a hotel without a barrier. And then... Do you put the remote in a Ziploc bag before you use it? I put it in a pot of boiling water. And then if it still works, we're on it.
难道杰森不会走在酒店的地板上吗？如果没有防护措施，他是绝对不会走在酒店地板上的。然后……你用保鲜袋把遥控器装起来才用吗？我把它放进一锅开水里煮。然后如果它还能用，我们就用它。
But if it doesn't work, then there's no TV. So, you take the pillowcase. Jason basically lives like Howard Hughes. He has, like at all times, don't show him your fingernails. And he's got like 12 layers of Kleenex between himself and anything that he touches. You're bringing your own pillow,
但如果它不能用了，那就没电视看。所以，你带着枕头套。杰森基本上过着霍华德·休斯式的生活。他随时随地，千万别让他看你的指甲。而且他在自己和任何他接触的东西之间，隔着大约12层克林耐克斯纸巾。你带着自己的枕头，
but you're using their pillowcase. Because you want to make... Well, and he watched this. Well, no, what happened, it's worse than that. I took one pillowcase from the first hotel on this tour. Where did it start? We started in Portland, Maine, maybe. I took a pillowcase
但你用的是他们的枕套。因为你想弄清楚……嗯，而且他看着这个。嗯，不，事情的经过是，比那还要糟糕。我从这次巡演的第一家酒店拿了一个枕头套。是从哪里开始的？我们可能是在缅因州波特兰开始的。我拿了一个枕头套，
and it's still on. Because you like the thread count on that one. You're like, oh, we're gonna keep this. I liked that it was long and my special foam pillow is longer than a regular pillow too. So, it was cool. It was a nice fit.
而且到现在还留着。因为你喜欢那个枕套的纱支密度。你当时想，哦，我们要把这个留着。我喜欢它很长，而且我的特制海绵枕头也比普通枕头长。所以，这很酷。尺寸很合适。
You sleep with the pillow between your knees? I got one of those at an As Seen On TV store at Foxwoods recently. Oh, is it like a body pillow? No, it's like a little... It looks like a yoga block, except it has a skate ramp in it. And you put it right between those knees.
你睡觉时把枕头夹在膝盖中间吗？我最近在福克斯伍兹的一家“电视购物”商店里买了一个那种东西。哦，它就像一个长条抱枕吗？不，它就像一个小……它看起来像一个瑜伽砖，除了里面有一个滑板坡道。你把它直接放在两膝之间。
And it's at the... If you guys are at anyone near the As Seen On TV store at the mall in Foxwoods, the Casino, they have them there. And again, that's at the Foxwoods Casino. They're at Outlet Malls in the Damascus. Sean's a slow writer, so not too fast. Is there really a store called As Seen On TV?
它在……如果你们在福克斯伍兹购物中心的电视购物店附近，赌场里，他们就在那里卖。再说一次，那是在福克斯伍兹赌场。它们在达马斯科斯的奥特莱斯购物中心。肖恩是个慢热的作家，所以别太快。真的有一家叫“电视购物”的店吗？
Yeah. Oh yeah, you've never been in a mall. You've never seen them? Come on. Oh, it's the greatest. Truly. It looks like a storage unit. Can I ask you what they sell in there?
对。哦，对，你从来没去过商场。你从来没见过它们？拜托。哦，那是最棒的。真的。它看起来像一个储藏室。我能问问他们在里面卖什么吗？
I mean, the one thing I was really intrigued by this time was something called Battery Daddy, which was... It looked like a... Tell me slow. It looked like a CD tower. Looked like a compact disc tower for batteries. It was a big... It was almost like a pyramid
我的意思是，我这次真的很感兴趣的一样东西叫做“电池老爸”，它是一个……它看起来像一个……说慢点。它看起来像一个CD塔。看起来像一个放电池的激光唱片塔。它是一个大型的……它几乎像一个金字塔，
where all your sizes of batteries had different levels they could clip into. Could you use that? Definitely can't find the double A's when I need them. Could you use that? Now, do you guys keep your batteries in the freezer, by the way? Or am I just married to a crazy person?
你所有的电池尺寸都有不同的层数可以卡进去。你能用上那个吗？需要的时候绝对找不到5号电池。你能用上那个吗？话说回来，你们平时把电池放在冰箱里吗？还是说我只是娶了个疯子？
No, I don't think there's any science behind that. What are you, a photographer, what's going on? I used to... I got one of those wedge pillows where you can slip your arm because my arm was bothering me for a while and I bought it from, I think, with the back store and one of these things, relax the back. And you actually put your hand...
不，我觉得那背后没什么科学依据。你是什么人，摄影师，这到底是怎么回事？我以前……我买了一个那种楔形枕头，你可以把胳膊塞进去，因为我的胳膊有一段时间很不舒服，我是从——我想是在“背部商店”买的，就是其中一家，放松背部商店。然后你实际上把手放进去……
It looked like a mousetrap. And then I'd sleep on this thing. Anyway, I did it at work. What a catch. You have a CPAP when you go to sleep too? Sean, do you... I don't. Sean, do you...
它看起来像个捕鼠器。然后我就睡在这东西上。不管怎样，我在工作中这么做了。真是个活宝。你睡觉时也戴呼吸机吗？肖恩，你……我没有。肖恩，你……
My girlfriend, Olivia, has still... We still have the pregnancy pillow, that horseshoe-shaped thing. And I slept in it the other day and it is fantastic. It's like sleeping in a bumper bowling lane. I woke up with something. Sean sleeps like in that position,
我女朋友奥利维亚仍然——我们还留着那个孕妇枕，就是那个马蹄形的玩意儿。前几天我枕着它睡了一觉，简直棒极了。就像睡在保龄球道的挡板里一样。我醒来时身上有点……肖恩睡觉的姿势就像那种，
they tell you again when a plane's crashing, like with his grabbing his knees. Just in case Scotty wakes up, real antsy. I never feel rested. I never feel rested. I saw an interview with Donnie Osman once where he was extolling the virtues of sleeping on the tray on a commercial flight.
飞机失事时他们再次告诉你的那种姿势，比如抱着双膝。万一斯科蒂醒来，特别烦躁不安的话。我从来没有觉得休息好过。我从来没有觉得休息好过。我曾经看过一个唐ny·奥斯蒙的采访，他在采访中大加赞赏在商业航班的小桌板上睡觉的好处。
Sleep on the... No, that always makes me want to vomit. And did he say, and make sure to drink 12 rums before you go to bed? I love you God, Donnie is a rum drinker. The cart. The cart. Yeah, not the cart.
睡在……不，那总是让我想吐。而且他有没有说，上床睡觉前一定要喝12杯朗姆酒？我爱你，上帝，唐尼是个朗姆酒鬼。推车。推车。对，不是推车。
Top shell. Top shell. Wait, I want to get back to this long professional and personal relationships you have with the guy who let you into the improv group, which is Nick Kroll. The wonderful Nick Kroll. The wonderful Nick Kroll.
顶级好货。顶级好货。等等，我想回到你和那个带你进入即兴喜剧团的人之间长期的职业和个人关系，也就是尼克·克罗尔。了不起的尼克·克罗尔。了不起的尼克·克罗尔。
My best friend, older brother and everything. Mentor. Okay, well, we got it now. We got it in writing and in recording. We got it. Yeah, I know. That's, I sound good. It sounds gracious.
我最好的朋友、老大哥兼一切。导师。好吧，现在我们知道了。我们有文字和录音为证。我们知道了。对，我知道。这听起来不错。听起来很大度。
I sound gracious because he led me into the group and now just air it unedited. You've been paying him back ever since. But you guys, no, it did. You guys are like brothers and you guys have worked together so much now over the last however many years since you've known each other.
我听起来很大度，因为是他带我进入这个组合的，现在直接未经剪辑地播出去吧。你从那以后一直在报答他。但是你们，不，确实如此。你们就像兄弟一样，而且在你们认识彼此以来的这些年里，你们现在合作了那么多。
And 20. Is that like a thing that you guys consciously say or do you come back together every couple of years or you're like, or you go, you do your own thing. You're like, hey, let's go and do this. Or we, I don't know, how does it work? Well, let's see. For a while we, that's a good question.
这就像是你们有意识地说好要这么做，还是每隔几年你们就重新聚在一起，或者你们会说，或者你们各干各的。你们会说，嘿，我们去搞这个吧。或者我们，我不知道，这到底是怎么运作的？好吧，让我们看看。有一段时间我们，这是一个好问题。
We don't consciously plan, you know, let's work together in 18 months. We love working with each other. So he'd be my first thought for anyone to collaborate with. And then we have things that we've done consistently like the theater show, Oh Hello, where we played these two guys, Gil and George. We did that in a variety of media
我们并没有刻意计划，你知道的，让我们在18个月后合作。我们喜欢和彼此合作。所以对于任何人来说，他都会是我合作的第一人选。然后我们有一些一直坚持在做的事情，比如戏剧演出《哦，你好》，我们在其中扮演这两个家伙，吉尔和乔治。我们在各种媒介中表演过，
and then did it as a play on Broadway. So like that's a thing where we will talk about revisiting those characters specifically. And then obviously I work with him on Big Mouth on Netflix but I, but he's along with Andrew Goldberg and Mark and Jen Flack and he's a creator EP. So I'm not doing that with him, but I'm lucky enough to be on it.
然后把它作为一出百老汇戏剧上演。所以，这就像是我们会专门讨论重新审视这些角色的事情。然后显而易见，我在网飞的《大嘴》中与他合作，但我，但他与安德鲁·戈德堡、马克以及詹·弗拉克一起，他是创作者兼执行制片人。所以我不是在和他一起做这个，但我很幸运能参演。
You're on it. Big Mouth for Tracy is a really funny, very popular animated show on Netflix. It's been on for five, four, five years. Tracy might even know that. Yeah, she might know that. She's already moved on to human resources. She might know that.
你参演了。特蕾西的《大嘴》是一部非常搞笑、非常受欢迎的网飞动画剧集。已经播了五年、四年、五年了。特蕾西可能甚至知道这一点。对，她可能知道。她已经转向人力资源部了。她可能知道这一点。
And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Hey, John, with all the things that you do and do well, how do you decide what to do? Is it informed by some sort of a five-year plan that you've got? No, never had a five-year plan. What about next week, next month?
我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。嘿，约翰，鉴于你所做的一切以及你所擅长的一切，你是如何决定该做什么的？它是由你制定的某种五年计划决定的吗？不，从来没有过五年计划。那下周、下个月呢？
I'm a little, I remember a professor in college said, someone was like, someone said, just taking it one day at a time and he said, that's great. Of course, Malaney lives minute to minute and like everyone laughed. And I was really like, what is it? It was odd of him to call that out in the middle of a Jewish studies class, but.
我有点，我记得大学里的一位教授说过，当时有人在说，有人说，只要过好当下的每一天，而他说，那太棒了。当然，马拉尼是按分秒生活的，然后大家都笑了。我当时真的很想，那是什么？他在犹太研究课上当众指出这一点，这真是挺奇怪的，不过。
You have no sort of North Star, whether you get there or not, at least it's giving you direction and forming. I'd love a knockout obituary and great speeches at the memorial service. But then I can't think, you know. You just want it to be glowing. What do you want your tombstone to say?
你没有任何类似于北极星的东西，不管你能否到达那里，至少它能给你指明方向并塑造你。我希望有一个轰动的讣告和追悼会上精彩的演讲。但随后我就想不了那么多，你知道的。你只希望它是光芒四射的。你希望你的墓碑上写些什么？
I've thought about this recently. If it could say anything. You know, I was walking around a cemetery in Connecticut where all the. Where you do? Where you do. And the graves are from like the 1700s. And back then people would,
我最近一直在想这个。如果它能写任何东西的话。你知道的，我当时在康涅狄格州的一个公墓里闲逛，那里所有的……你做的那里。你做的地方。那里的坟墓大约是1700年代的。那时候人们会，
I walked by a grave that said, handsome and brave. Dude, I'm so. It was like a hero of the revolution, handsome and brave. I was like, I think I'm gonna take that. Yes. So this is what I thought. I was thinking the other, I was walking around a cemetery a couple of years ago,
我走过一座坟墓，上面写着：英俊而勇敢。伙计，我太……那就像是一个革命英雄，英俊而勇敢。我当时想，我想选那个。对，所以我是这么想的。我当时在想别的，几年前我在一个公墓里闲逛，
one night and not a big, just cause it was a better, you know, I get a better view inside the window of the, it doesn't matter, longer story. Anyway, obviously for a lawyer, I can't say why. Of course. But reading all the grave stones, I was thinking like, I would want to put something like, he was a cool guy.
有一天晚上，不是很大的公墓，只是因为能更好地看到窗户里面的风景，这不重要，说来话长。不管怎样，显而易见对于一个律师来说，我不能说原因。当然。但读着所有的墓碑，我在想，我会想写一些类似的话，他是个很酷的家伙。
That's it. Because then if I saw that, I'd be like, who the fuck is that motherfucker? He was a cool guy. You know what I just, I just read, I read that you can now get your body turned into compost and you can, you know, use it to plant a tree or something. Take six months to turn it into compost.
就这样。因为如果我看到那个，我会想，那个混蛋到底是谁？他是个很酷的家伙。你知道我刚刚，我刚读到，我读到你现在可以让你的身体变成堆肥，然后你可以，你知道的，用它来种一棵树什么的。花六个月时间把它变成堆肥。
They just keep mixing the guts with dirt over and over again. That's what happens when you just fucking bury a body. What do you think the body does in the ground by itself? It's a pickup truck worth of compost. So that just sounds like compost with a dead body in it. It doesn't sound like your body is doing anything. It does. That's a good point.
他们只是不断地把内脏和泥土搅拌在一起。当你他妈的把尸体埋了的时候，发生的不就是这事吗？你觉得尸体在地下自己会干什么？它本身就是满满一小卡车价值的堆肥。所以这听起来只是带有一具死尸的堆肥。听起来并不像你的身体在做任何事情。确实如此。这倒是个好观点。
Your gash is unembalmed body, exploding in reusable compost. I would love to see your search history though, Sean. You know, I did. I looked at all. So with the FBI, why didn't you buy all that lime? What's going on? I'd like, you know, I would like it said at my funeral
你那具未经防腐处理的躯壳，在可重复使用的堆肥中爆炸。不过肖恩，我很想看看你的搜索记录。你知道的，我看了所有的。所以对于联邦调查局来说，你为什么不买那些生石灰呢？这到底是怎么回事？我希望，你知道的，我希望在我的葬礼上说，
or on my gravestone that I, some of my flaws, like he was late a lot and people talked to him about it and he was still late. Are you still? Are you still late? I'm getting better at it. I'm getting better at it. Do you know why you're late?
或者在我的墓碑上写着我的一些缺点，比如他经常迟到，人们跟他谈过这事，但他还是迟到。你现在还这样吗？你现在还迟到吗？我在变好。我在变好。你知道你为什么迟到吗？
I think, well, one Saturday Night Live completely destroyed my relationship with time in that meetings that were supposed to begin at 3 p.m. would begin at 5 p.m. or 6 p.m. with no explanation or apology. So after a couple of years there, I would meet people 45 minutes late and not think I needed to say anything regarding where I'd been.
我觉得，嗯，首先《周六夜现场》彻底摧毁了我对时间的观念，原本应该在下午3点开始的会议，会在下午5点或6点开始，没有任何解释或道歉。所以在那里呆了几年之后，我会迟到45分钟去见别人，并且觉得不需要就我去过哪里做任何解释。
Wow. Yeah. And then I think I'm better. I must think I'm better than everyone else. I mean, everyone else, I guess. What about having a kid now? Kid really puts you on a schedule, right? No, a kid put me on a schedule
哇。对，然后我想我比别人强。我是说，其他人，我猜。现在有了孩子感觉怎么样？孩子确实让你过上了有规律的生活，对吧？不，有了孩子确实让我过上了有规律的生活，
and I have made a big resolution to be on time, be where I said I'll be, when I said I'll be there. And I've actually been good about that. Yeah. Sean, Sean said I'm gonna be outside a fire station all day today and I'm gonna say he is. It's, I live in, yeah, in the middle of. What is your, what do you think you're best at being a dad?
而且我下定决心要准时，去我答应过要去的地方，在我答应过的时间到那里。而且我实际上在这方面做得很好。对。肖恩，肖恩说我今天一整天都要待在消防局外面，而且我会说他确实在那儿。这，我住在，对，在……你觉得你当爸爸最擅长的是什么？
What do you think you're worst at being a dad? Oh, I know we're early days and we're just trying stuff out. Best at. Swaddle technique. I am a good swaddler. Yeah. I am a good swaddler.
你觉得你当爸爸最不擅长的是什么？哦，我知道现在还处于早期阶段，我们还在尝试各种方法。最擅长的是。包裹技术。我是一个很会用包被裹婴儿的人。对。我是一个很会包裹婴儿的人。
I learned to swaddle somewhat from Ozarks. You give a brief swaddle tutorial, if you recall. Sean. And we were waiting on. You're not supposed to watch that. Oh my God. What was your favorite episode? I love the one where you're,
我多多少少是从《黑钱胜地》里学会怎么包裹婴儿的。你能简单演示一下包裹婴儿的技巧吗，如果你还记得的话。肖恩。我们在等……你不该看那个。天哪。你最喜欢哪一集？我喜欢你正在的那集，
I love the one where you're laundering all the money. And you know, everyone's like, oh my God, you know. People check out that the department store, those glory holes and they swaddle sometimes. They sure do. Is that right? Good at swaddling. I'm good at, I know when tummy time is over.
我喜欢你正在洗钱的那集。你知道的，每个人都觉得，哦，天哪，你知道的。人们去百货公司的那些荣耀洞查看，有时他们会包裹婴儿。他们还真这么干。是这样吗？擅长包裹婴儿。我很擅长，我知道什么时候趴着玩的时间该结束了。
Before Little Malcolm gives me that look like, Jesus man, you gonna get me out of here? I know it's time. I know that big head is starting to get a little tired of bobbing up and down. I probably am worse at overthinking how to approach him as an adolescent, which I really don't need to worry about
在小马尔科姆给我那种眼神，就像是，天哪老兄，你要带我离开这里吗？之前，我就知道时候到了。我知道那个大脑袋开始有点厌倦上下晃动了。我可能最不擅长的是过度思考该如何以一个青少年的方式接近他，其实我根本不需要为此担心，
for the next few years. But I am constantly running scenarios of what kind of parent I'll be when he's 11, 12, 13. The combo between being a dad versus being a best friend? Oh, just like, yeah. And will I be, in my mind I was like, I'm gonna be this like semi-stern. I'm gonna kind of be like my dad with him
在接下来的几年里。但我一直在脑海中演练各种场景，当他11岁、12岁、13岁时我会成为什么样的家长。在当爸爸和当挚友之间如何权衡？哦，就像是，对。我会不会，在我的脑海里我想的是，我会成为那种半严肃的人。我会有点像我爸爸那样对待他，
and that's all falling apart in four months. I can't imagine ever criticizing anything this kid does or. But who do you, I mean, you know, Olivia knows you. Have you guys, has it become clear who's gonna be the disciplinarian, who's gonna be the nurturer? Oh, that's a good question. She's such a wonderful mother and so nurturing
而这一切在四个月内就彻底瓦解了。我无法想象自己会去批评这个孩子的任何行为，或者。但你觉得，我是说，你知道的，奥利维亚了解你。你们俩之间，谁会成为严厉的管教者，谁会成为温柔的培育者，这变得明朗了吗？哦，这是一个好问题。她是一位如此出色的母亲，如此悉心培育，
and also- Here it comes, here it comes. Well, I mean, right now she's extremely nurturing, but she can be extremely organized. She has packing cubes. That was a good choice of words. Great choice. Thanks guys. Now she can listen.
而且还——来了，来了。好吧，我的意思是，现在她极其悉心培育，但她也可以极其有条理。她有打包收纳盒。那个词用得真好。绝佳的选择。谢谢你们，伙计们。现在她可以听着了。
So she's very good about organizing. Does that allow you to be- She's very organized, very disciplined in a way that I'm not. However, I don't know when it comes to Malcolm. The ideal I have for myself is that I come home in a suit, which is gonna be hard working at home and that, and that there's some expectation of your dad is home and therefore that, you know, that's intimidating,
所以她在收纳方面非常有一套。这能让你——她非常有条理，非常有纪律性，而我则不然。然而，我不知道当涉及到马尔科姆时会怎样。我对自己的理想设想是，我穿着西装回家——这对于在家工作来说很难——而且会有某种“你爸爸回家了”的期望，因此，你知道的，这会有所震慑，
but I absolutely will never follow through on that. My oldest brother, Dennis, when he had, he has three kids, he would let them with crayons draw all over the walls in every room. And of course, he, that would upset his wife and they would discuss it and he was like, let him be kids, let him have like and do anything they want. You can paint over that crayons.
但我绝对无法坚持做到这一点。我最大的哥哥丹尼斯，当他有——他有三个孩子，他会让他们用蜡笔在每个房间的墙上到处画画。当然，他，这会惹恼他的妻子，他们会讨论这事，而他会说，让他们做孩子吧，让他们有想要的生活，做他们想做的任何事情。你可以把蜡笔画刷掉。
Like, would you ever do anything like that? Well, here's, and it should be noted also, it came from like Sean, you know, Sean's dad never got mad at them drawing on the walls or anything. He didn't get mad at them doing anything. He would just what? Now, the reason is he wasn't there, but, but. Well, if they hide the car keys, he'd hate that.
就像，你会做类似的事情吗？好吧，这里是，而且应该指出的是，这源于——就像肖恩，你知道的，肖恩的爸爸从来没有因为他们在墙上画画而生气过。他从不因为他们做任何事而生气。他只会怎样？现在，原因是他根本不在场，但是，但是。好吧，如果他们藏了车钥匙，他会恨死那事的。
That's the thing that would piss him off. Absolutely no chance of escaping, really piss him off. Who took my to me carry on? He was always mad. Who took my weekend? His dad left like, like Cal-L leaving Krypton, like just on his own, like an escape pod. You know what I mean?
那是会惹毛他的事。绝对没有逃脱的可能，真的会惹毛他。谁拿了我的随身行李？他总是很生气。谁拿了我的周末？他爸爸离开的方式，就像卡尔-艾尔离开氪星一样，就像他独自一人坐着逃生舱离开。你知道我的意思吗？
I don't know if that represents, right? Yes, of course I got that. Well, Will, Will and Jason, here's what I wonder. If I, I remember a good friend of mine when we were six to his dad, he was so mad at his dad. And he said, Sayonara, sucker, motherfucker. And his dad, his dad acted mad and I, as I've gotten older, I'm like, can, I don't know how I won't laugh
我不知道这是否能代表，对吧？是的，我当然明白了。好吧，威尔，威尔和杰森，我一直在想这个。如果我，我记得我一个好朋友，我们六岁时对他的爸爸说，他对他爸爸气极了。他说：再见啦，白痴，混蛋。而他爸爸，他爸爸表现得很生气，随着我年龄的增长，我心想，如果我，
if my kid ever like tells me off. It just will be, if Malcolm ever yells at me, it seems like such a funny moment that I won't be able to not laugh. Well, we have put it this way. I have videos of both my kids having, having breakdowns or tantrums at various ages cause they're so fucking hilarious, which I show them now.
如果我的孩子以后对我说狠话，我怎么可能不笑呢。这只会是，如果马尔科姆对大喊大叫，那听起来会是一个如此搞笑的时刻，以至于我根本忍不住不笑。好吧，我们换个说法。我有我两个孩子在不同年龄段情绪崩溃或发脾气的视频，因为他们他妈的太搞笑了，我现在把这些给他们看。
And even in the moment, you recognize how funny, like Abel, we have one Abel saying when he was little and he was like, something, something, because you're the worst. And you can see him go in the moment, go, I mean, not the worst. I mean, you're kind of great and I love you. So he walks it back in the middle of his thing.
甚至在当时，你也能意识到它是多么搞笑，比如阿贝尔，我们有一个视频是阿贝尔小时候说的，他当时说，什么什么，因为你是最糟糕的。你能看到他在当时说，我是说，不是最糟糕的。我是说，你其实挺棒的，我爱你。所以他在话说了一半时又收回去了。
And then the other day, when it Abel said to me that, the other day it went to wake him up for school. I think I told you guys this. And I go up and he's, he's 11. His eyes aren't even open yet. And I go up and I go, hey buddy, we gotta get out. We gotta get to school. His eyes not even open and he goes, play is gonna play.
然后前几天，当阿贝尔对我说，前几天我去叫他起床去上学。我想我跟你们说过这个。我走过去，他当时是，他11岁。他的眼睛甚至都还没睁开，我走过去说，嘿，伙计，我们得出发了。我们得去学校。他眼睛甚至都没睁开，就说：戏剧就是戏剧。
I'm like, what? Play is gonna play. They constantly surprise you. That's the thing. And you have no idea how you're gonna react. And you just kind of go with it and I don't know. Speaking of not knowing how to react, hecklers, what's a good heckler story?
我说：什么？戏剧就是戏剧。他们不断地给你带来惊喜。就是这样。而且你根本不知道自己会做何反应。你只能顺其自然，我不知道。说到不知道该怎么反应，起哄者，有什么好的起哄故事吗？
Cause you're on tour right now, right? For you, Sean. Thanks. From scratch, right? Back to the list. I emailed my, I emailed my bullet points. He doesn't know how to. No, but I love those stories.
因为你现在正在巡演，对吧？为了你，肖恩。谢谢。从零开始，对吧？回到清单上。我给我发了，我给我发了要点。他不知道怎么……不，但我喜欢那些故事。
I love heckler stories. The best, I got, I was doing Bonnaroo one year. I was doing, there was a big comedy tent at the Bonnaroo music festival in Murfreesboro, Tennessee. And someone said, we've signed you up to do a show with the VIP camping ground, like the organizers of the festival. And I said, what's that about?
我喜欢起哄者的故事。最棒的是，有一年我在参加博纳鲁音乐节。我在做，田纳西州默弗里斯伯勒的博纳鲁音乐节上有一个巨大的喜剧帐篷。有人说，我们已经给你报名了，要在VIP露营地做一场演出，也就是音乐节的组织者那里。我说，那是怎么回事？
And they said, just get on the back of this golf cart. And they drove so fast in the back of a golf cart, which is like falling out of a chair forever. And they, I get to this, like, I get to a plywood stage and there's all these RVs and there's like a micro brew truck giving out beer to these VIP glampers. Oh, you can handle, yeah.
他们说，只要坐到这辆高尔夫球车的后面就行。他们开着高尔夫球车在后面开得飞快，那感觉就像永远从椅子上摔下来一样。然后我到了这里，就像，我到了一处胶合板舞台，周围全都是房车，还有一辆精酿啤酒卡车在向这些VIP豪华露营者分发啤酒。哦，你能应付，对吧。
And they had no idea someone had been brought in to do standup and they, they didn't ask for it. They didn't want it. They didn't like it. I was not someone they knew who that was. I was not someone people were excited to see. And I started doing standup and this guy yelled, I think I speak for everyone when I say,
他们完全不知道有人被请来表演脱口秀，而且他们并没有要求这个。他们不想要这个。他们不喜欢这个。我不是他们认识的人，不是那种大家都很兴奋想见到的人。我开始表演脱口秀，然后这家伙大喊道：我想我代表了大家的意见，
we'd enjoy silence more than the sound of your voice. Oh my God. And it was so articulate. It was very polite. How do you, how do you heckle back at that? I went, I went, I, hey, fuck you. Sucker motherfucker. Yeah.
比起你的声音，我们更享受安静。天哪。而且表达得那么清晰。非常有礼貌。你该怎么，怎么对那种言论进行回击呢？我说，我说了，嘿，去你的吧。白痴混蛋。对。
Sayonara, sucker motherfucker, jump on the back of the golf cart, speed away. That actually be a good, I might close a special with that. Sayonara, sucker motherfucker. After a really gracious thank you to the audience, I turn around and then say Sayonara, sucker, it's funny. It'd be so great if that became your calling card,
再见啦，白痴混蛋，跳上高尔夫球车，飞驰而去。那实际上会是个不错的，我可能会用那个来给专场收尾。再见啦，白痴混蛋。在对观众表达了非常真诚的感谢之后，我转过身去，然后说：再见啦，白痴，这挺搞笑的。如果那成了你的招牌动作，那该有多棒啊，
farewell to your audience. Yeah, this, this aggressive, shitty little group. I would, I have this, I have this masochistic fantasy of doing one set of standup, but I would have no idea how to, how to write a session. Have you ever heard of, you know, yeah. I mean, the very fact that you call it a session is not.
向你的观众告别。对，这个好斗的、讨厌的小群体。我会，我有这种虐待狂般的幻想，想要做一场脱口秀，但我完全不知道该怎么写一个专场。你听说过，你知道的，对。我的意思是，你居然把它叫做专场，这本身就不太……
Session, you know. But you know how like some, some. I'm here to perform a session. Guys, listen up, I'm here to perform a session. Well, you know, like how some music acts, they don't write their own music, but they perform them. Well, have you ever heard of a standup
专场，你知道的。但你知道有些，有些。我是来表演专场的。伙计们，听好了，我是来表演专场的。好吧，你知道的，就像有些音乐艺人，他们不自己写歌，但他们进行表演。好吧，你听说过有哪个脱口秀演员，
having a whole set written for he or she, and then they do it? Yeah, I mean, there are, there are, and it's kind of more of an older school thing. Like there were performers who had a lot of writers and there were, you know, I really don't hear about it much anymore. There are people who do standup,
拥有一整套由别人为他或她写好的段子，然后他们去表演吗？是的，我的意思是，确实有，而且这更偏向于老派的做法。比如有些表演者有很多编剧，而且有，你知道的，我真的很少再听到这种事了。有些人做脱口秀，
who also do so many other types of sessions that acting sessions and directing sessions that they eventually have writers, but most people seem to. Why don't you go to an open session night? Are there? Yeah, go to open session. I'd actually like to end standup
他们同时也做许多其他类型的专场，比如表演专场和导演专场，以至于他们最终有了编剧，但大多数人似乎都是……你为什么不去参加一个开放麦之夜？有吗？对，去参加开放麦。其实我想以我心理医生结束咨询的方式来结束脱口秀，
the way my therapist ends sessions, which is, okay, we have to pause now. Yeah, there you go. And then just walk off stage. Jason, have you seen any good comedy routines lately? You know, would you like to go see some routines? There's some wonderful routines out there at the improv, which is short for the improvisation.
那就是：好了，我们现在必须暂停了。对，就是这样。然后直接走下舞台。杰森，你最近看过什么好看的喜剧表演吗？你知道的，你想去看一些表演吗？在即兴喜剧俱乐部有很多精彩的表演，“即兴”的简称。
They're on Melrose Avenue. I like when people call like adults call, like my brother go, I'm doing a play here in Chicago. And he goes, you got play practice today? Yeah. You mean rehearsal? Is this Dennis with the three kids? Yeah.
它们在梅尔罗斯大道上。我喜欢人们称呼——成年人这样称呼，就像我哥哥说：我在芝加哥有一场戏剧。然后他说：你今天有戏剧排练吗？对。你是说彩排？这是那个带着三个孩子的丹尼斯吗？对。
Hey, I don't want to bug you. I know you're in the middle of play practice, but play practice. I know you're drilling the play. I do like saying practice instead of rehearsal when we're on set. That is fun. I do like yelling at a hockey game, shoot the ball.
嘿，我不想打扰你。我知道你正忙着排练戏剧，不过排练戏剧。我知道你在排练这出戏。我们在片场时，确实喜欢用“练习”来代替“彩排”。那挺好玩的。我确实喜欢在冰球比赛中大喊：把球射出去！
I do like that. Oh man. Put that in your standup. Yeah. Oh God. Great idea. Yeah. You got a great start.
我确实喜欢那样。哦，天哪。把这个写进你的脱口秀里。对。哦，天哪。好主意。对。你开了个好头。
John Mulaney, we've taken up way too much of your time. Way too much. The tour is from scratch. I know that. Why is that? We could talk to Mulaney forever. I know. I don't want to.
约翰·马拉尼，我们占用了你太多时间了。太多了。这次巡演叫《从零开始》。我知道。为什么会这样？我们可以和马拉尼聊上一整天。我知道。我不想。
He's probably got shit to do. What an encore. How about an encore? We could do, we could just do another one where we follow up on everything we didn't finish. Which is everything. Every thread. We start just every little thread.
他可能还有一堆破事要忙。多棒的返场啊。来个返场怎么样？我们可以，我们可以再来一次，跟进我们没有聊完的所有事情。也就是所有事情。每一个话题。我们刚开始聊每一个小话题。
We don't like that. We like to keep a million tabs open. You know, it's just, I know it's. This browser has a lot of tabs open. We're the worst. We're the worst interviewers. No, you're the greatest. And I wouldn't want it any other way.
我们不喜欢那样。我们喜欢保持数百万个标签页打开。你知道的，这只是，我知道……这个浏览器打开了很多标签页。我们是最糟糕的。我们是最糟糕的采访者。不，你们是最棒的。我才不想有任何改变呢。
You know, I mean, I think it was Vivek Murthy who said to you guys, I've had a great time. I've had a really good time on the show. You see the way he brought it all the way back around you guys? And this is what a pro does. That's how you end a session. Double callbacks. Johnny, we love you.
你知道的，我的意思是，我觉得是维韦克·穆尔蒂对你们说过：我度过了一段美好的时光。我在节目里度过了一段非常美好的时光。你看到他是怎么把话题完美地绕回你们身上的吗？这就是专业人士的做法。这才是结束专场的方式。双重回扣。约翰尼，我们爱你。
Thank you for your time. I love you guys. This was really fun. This was really fun. Johnny, you're the best. Thank you for having me. This was really great. Thanks, buddy.
谢谢你抽出时间。我爱你们。这真的很有趣。这真的很有趣。约翰尼，你是最棒的。谢谢你邀请我。这真的很棒。谢谢，伙计。
Bye, buddy. Bye, Johnny. Thanks, John. Bye. At John Mulaney, he's a smooth operator. So funny. Every time I see him on SNL, even in the sketches, I laugh out loud.
再见，伙计。再见，约翰尼。谢谢，约翰。再见。致约翰·马拉尼，他是个左右逢源的滑头。太搞笑了。每次我在《周六夜现场》看到他，甚至是在小品里，我都哈哈大笑。
He seems like a good guy. I've never met him before. You're right, he is. He's the shodday of comedy. He's a smooth operator. Oh, nice. That's great. Thank you, man.
他看起来是个好人。我以前从未见过他。你说得对，他确实是。他是喜剧界的“舒迪”。他是个左右逢源的滑头。哦，太棒了。太棒了。谢谢你，伙计。
And doesn't stop. Like he just keeps writing and writing and writing and doing stuff. I just don't, I'm so envious. Like I don't, first of all, I can't write. I don't know how to write well. And then just to keep writing all that stuff that works all the time.
而且他从不停歇。就像他一直在写、写、写，一直在做事。我只是不，我太嫉妒了。首先，我不会写作。我不知道该怎么写好。然后还能一直写出那些随时都行之有效的东西。
And all those Netflix specials, it's crazy. Yeah, it's a lot of stuff. And doing touring and touring with stuff for a year or a year and a half, and then doing a special. And then immediately, like you got a sense of his work ethic. His show ends production, you know, this was years ago. And the next week he's out on tour for a year. And then has a special like eight months later, like what?
还有所有那些网飞专场，这太疯狂了。对，有很多东西。而且还要去巡演，带着段子巡演一年或一年半，然后做一个专场。接着立刻，就像你能感受到他的职业道德一样。他的剧集制作刚结束，你知道的，这都是几年前的事了。然后第二周他就出去巡演一年。接着大约八个月后又有一个专场，就像是：什么鬼？
And enjoys the hotels and the buses. Like, that's not for me. I wonder how that's going to go now with the kid. You know, like, is he going to be able to be happy about being on the road all the time? Well, we know how that goes. It changes. It changes everything.
而且还享受酒店和大巴的生活。这可不适合我。我很好奇有了孩子之后这会变成什么样。你知道的，就像，他还能一直开开心心地在路上巡演吗？好吧，我们知道会变成什么样。一切都变了。一切都变了。
And you get like, yeah, you know, it's... You better start working on that sitcom. It's hard. It's hard, as you know. The sitcom works for being a dad though, right? It sure does. Yeah, why doesn't everybody just do a sitcom? Right, just do that for the first 10 years.
然后你会觉得，对，你知道的，这……你最好开始筹备那部情景喜剧了。这很难。如你所知，这很难。不过情景喜剧对于当爸爸来说挺合适的，对吧？确实如此。对，为什么不是所有人都在拍情景喜剧呢？
Cause I heard somebody they're like, oh, like I'm working this hard jobs friend of mine in New York, like works in this office. Like, my job is so hard. I'm like, why don't you just get a sitcom and then you're at home with a dog? Cause you can just order those on Amazon, right? We just sign up for them.
对啊，头十年就拍那个呗。因为我听有人说他们就像是，哦，就像我在干这么累的工作，我在纽约的一个朋友，在办公室工作。就像，我的工作太难了。我就想，你为什么不去拍个情景喜剧，然后你就能带着狗在家呆着了？因为你可以在亚马逊上直接订购那些，对吧？我们只要注册就行了。
You're so stupid. Stop being such a stupid idiot and get a sitcom. But Malini is so, so, he's been so successful. And he just, you know, he's one of those like, he didn't sort of explode out of nowhere. Like he just kind of, he kind of built, he built, he built. Like Conan, like remember when Conan came on the scene and we were like, who the hell is this guy?
你太蠢了。别再当这种蠢货了，去拍个情景喜剧吧。但马拉尼是如此，如此，他太成功了。而且他，你知道的，他是那种人，他并不是凭空突然爆红的。他就像是，他一步一个脚印地建立，建立，建立。就像柯南，就像还记得柯南刚出道的时候，我们都在想：这家伙到底是谁？
He's, he's got the talk show now. It's like, no, well, if you look at his resume, like this guy has been a beast for a long time. But the SNL, the ones that Malini hosts, the SNLs that Malini hosts are always rated huge. Yeah, of course. Which is why they keep bringing him back because he's hilarious and he always delivers.
他现在有自己的脱口秀了。这就好像是，不，如果你看看他的简历，这家伙早就已经是块料了。但是《周六夜现场》，由马拉尼主持的那些，《周六夜现场》由马拉尼主持的节目收视率总是极高。对，当然。这就是为什么他们不断请他回来，因为他太搞笑了，而且他总能不负众望。
And so guess what? Turns out that that works in showbiz, Sean. Yeah. Try being good, Sean. Oh, shit, shit, shit, shit. I just realized. Are we still recording? Yeah.
所以你猜怎么着？事实证明，这在娱乐圈里行得通，肖恩。对。试着优秀一点，肖恩。哦，靠，靠，靠，靠。我刚意识到。我们还在录音吗？对。
I sell my headphones on, I can hear you. Sean, we didn't ask him his favorite color. What the fuck? Text him. Shit. Who got an email address for me? Hang on. No, well he did ask funny heckling story.
我戴着耳机呢，我能听见你们说话。肖恩，我们没有问他最喜欢的颜色是什么？他妈的？发短信给他。靠。谁有我的电子邮箱地址？等等。不，不过他确实问了关于有趣的起哄故事。
Yes. Because I just asked for just a general, that's up there with, what's your craziest audition story? But you know what it is, I realize about Sean. Don't you love those stories? No, I do. This is what I love about Sean. This is the reason I like it.
对。因为我刚刚问了一个一般性的问题，那就跟“你最疯狂的试镜经历是什么”差不多。但你知道是什么吗，我突然意识到了关于肖恩的事。难道你不喜欢那些故事吗？不，我是。这就是我喜欢肖恩的地方。这就是我喜欢它的原因。
This is really like, okay, this is why. And I'm like, it's because Sean likes those things when stuff goes really wrong in normal situations. He loves people freaking out. He used to love bloopers and practical jokes, right? And then those crazy home videos, right Sean? Don't you miss it? Do you wanna know what happened
这真的很像，好吧，这就是为什么。而我在想，这是因为肖恩喜欢那种在正常情况下事情彻底搞砸的事情。他喜欢看人们抓狂。他以前喜欢滑稽失误和恶作剧，对吧？还有那些疯狂的家庭录像，对吧肖恩？难道你不想念吗？你想知道发生了什么吗
to last Saturday late show at the play? Okay, yeah, of course. I shit you not, it was this long. I'm doing my, I have like seven monologues in the play. In the middle of one of my play, and there's two or three other actors on the stage. And- I love that you don't even know how many.
上周六晚上的那场戏？好吧，对，当然。我没骗你，有这么长。我在做我的，我在那部戏里大约有七个独白。在我的其中一段戏中间，舞台上有两到三个其他演员。而且——我喜欢你甚至不知道有几个。
Blanked out, completely blanked out. You did? Yeah, in the middle of my thing I go, yeah, so I'm telling this story, blah, blah, blah, blah, and sold out, by the way. And I look at Ethan, and I'm looking at him, I'm like, fucking please help me. I know my mind went complete.
脑子一片空白，完全一片空白。真的吗？对，在我的台词中间，我心想，好吧，所以我正在讲这个故事，巴拉巴拉巴拉巴拉，而且票卖光了，顺便说一句。我看着伊桑，我看着他，我心想：他妈的求求你帮帮我。我知道我的脑子彻底……
I'm like, no idea where I am. And then he says a line that skips about a page, and in my head I was like, thank you, but I don't think I can skip that because there's information the audience needs in order to know the story later. Right. So I was like, ah, ah, ah.
我心想：完全不知道我在哪儿。然后他说了一句台词，跳过了一整页，而在我的脑海里我心想：谢谢你，但我觉得我不能跳过那个，因为里面有观众为了了解后面的故事所需要的信息。所以我就想：啊，啊，啊。
No, it was that fucking awful. That long. What about somebody in the wings? Is anybody on book in the wings? I know, I said, and I said to the stage manager, she goes, I almost came on the God, Mike, and gave you your line. I go, just do it, who gives a shit?
不，那他妈的太可怕了。那么长。那侧幕的人呢？侧幕有跟台本的人吗？我知道，我说，我对舞台经理说，她差点就通过上帝麦克风上台把台词塞给我了。我说：直接这么干啊，谁他妈在乎？
I'm dying up there. But what about just kind of sauntering over to the wings in character to get a soda or something? You're in the back of the house. So what did you- So what happened? I fucking, I don't know, I somehow- You grabbed it and saved it?
我在上面快憋死了。但慢悠悠地走到侧幕去拿苏打水或者别的什么，保持着角色状态呢？你在舞台深处。所以你——所以发生了什么？我他妈的，我不知道，我不知怎么——你力挽狂澜把它救回来了？
I'm a miracle. And did the audience know, do you think? Yes, for sure. Really? A couple of friends are like, hey, did you? And I was like, yeah. Oh, yeah. Did they ask for any portion of their money back?
我真是个奇迹。你觉得观众知道吗？对，肯定的。真的吗？有几个朋友问我：嘿，你刚才……然后我说：对。哦，对。他们要求退还部分票钱吗？
Like, could you ask for like five bucks back? Here's the scariest part, Sean. Here's the scariest thing, and Sean, we love you. I love you too. You told us this story verbatim yesterday. Yeah. Once you lay down and get your ankles above your heart, Sean. This is so fucking-
比如，你能要求退回五块钱吗？最可怕的部分在这里，肖恩。最可怕的事情在这里，肖恩，我们爱你。我也爱你。你昨天一字不差地把这个故事给我们讲了一遍。对。等你躺下来，把脚踝抬到心脏上方再说，肖恩。这他妈的太——
Fuck, we love you. We love you so fucking much. We love you so fucking much. That's hysterical. Okay. Listen, by the way. Jason and Sean. Just to bring it back full circle.
操，我们爱你。我们他妈的太爱你们了。我们他妈的太爱你们了。这太滑稽了。好吧。听着，顺便说一句。杰森和肖恩。只是为了把话题做一个完美的总结。
Yeah. I'm gonna let you guys know, but I think that I have to go over to the store to check out the- The whole- The dress rooms or the bathroom. Because if, for no other reason than- Here comes, this is about- I'm really- Bye. Curious.
是的。我要告诉你们，但我想我得去店里看看——整个——试衣间或洗手间。因为如果不是为了别的，只是为了——来了，这关于——我真的很——再见。好奇。
Curious. There it is. Oh, we got it. Smart. What? Smart. What? Smart.
好奇。就是这样。哦，我们找到了。聪明。什么？聪明。什么？聪明。
What? Smart. What? Smart. What? What? What? This is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett
什么？聪明。什么？聪明。什么？什么？什么？这是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔姆贾尔夫和贝内特百分之百有机且手工制作的
Barbaco. Smart. What? Smart. What? Smart. What? Smart.
巴尔巴科亚。聪明。什么？聪明。什么？聪明。什么？聪明。
What? Smart. What? Smart. What? Smart. What? Smart.
什么？聪明。什么？聪明。什么？聪明。什么？聪明。
What? Smart. What? Smart. What? There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
什么？聪明。什么？聪明。什么？本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。